[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier we are just four days from
Tuesday's crucial midterm election hard
to believe four days president Trump is
right now halfway through a campaign
doubleheader on this final Friday in
addition to stumping for Republican
candidates the president is continuing
his hard sell on his signature issue for
this political season immigration and
border security but he's also riding a
positive wave of economic news in the
final days of this campaign chief White
House correspondent John Roberts starts
us off tonight as he often does this
time even the president's critics John
are saying this is a Steller's jobs
report you know there's no question
about that
brat back in 1992 you'll remember Bill
Clinton won the presidency on the mantra
it's the economy stupid back then the
economy was a bad news story today it's
a good news story but the question is
does good news motivate voters to the
polls in the same way that bad news does
President Trump certainly hope so
president Trump departed the White House
for campaign rallies in West Virginia
and Indiana today with another issue to
take to voters another month of strong
job creation and low unemployment
[Music]
but he also kept up the drumbeat on
illegal immigration at his first stop
insisting nothing less that America's
sovereignty is at stake Caravan after
Caravan is forming unvetted illegal
aliens trying to flood into our country
on your dollar overwhelming your
school's depleting your resources and
endangering your community the migrant
caravans are nowhere near the United
States yet today a dozen Hondurans in
the caravan sued President Trump for
denying them their fifth Amendment
rights to due process saying they have a
constitutional right to request asylum
asked about the lawsuit President Trump
today turned his fire on the Honduran
government they let their people come up
and they form their caravans in the
country they are doing nothing we're
paying them hundreds of millions of
dollars guess what that money's going to
stop very soon the president also
clarified a statement that raised
eyebrows yesterday when he seemed to
suggest the US military might use lethal
force if migrants try to force their way
across the border they want to throw
rocks at our military military fights
back we're gonna consider it item
consider a rifle today President Trump
said it's not his intention to have
anyone shooting anybody
but if our soldiers or Border Patrol
arrives I'm going to be hit in the face
where the rocks we're going to arrest
those people that doesn't mean shoot
them but we're going to arrest those
people quickly and for a long period of
time there also appeared to be some
movement on the China issue today
president Trump confirming he will meet
with President Xi at the g20 in Buenos
Aires later this month indicating China
may be changing its tune on trade they
very much want to make a deal as you
know their economy went way down since
we've been doing this skirmish
I spoke with presidency yesterday they
very much want to make a deal while
President Trump is optimistic about the
possibility of making a new trade deal
with China he is also prepared to take a
baseball bat to them threatening tariffs
on another 257 billion dollars worth of
Chinese goods if they don't play ball
right John Roberts lobbed the North Lawn
John thanks